dr house is out of control but so am i
let's watch this episode
9-1-1 what's your emergency we've got
into an accident along the canal road
just outside kingston
my mom's unconscious
are you hurt she should have asked us
she have a pulse and if not stir chest
compressions
i'm fine you're not fine you have a
metal object going through your body
oh
can we hurry this up make sure they take
your time
what's your name
[Music]
hannah morgenthau
you have cipa and a morgenthal what is
sipa i don't we have to do x-rays to
make sure you don't have internal
injuries blood tests to make sure no
infections eeg for neurological
anomalies and
biopsy a spinal nerve i love how he just
decided that because he didn't like how
she was responding to the alcohol on her
leg
and first of all who puts alcohol on a
leg all you need is a little soapy water
like alcohol actually disrupts the skin
tissue there only been about 60
documented cases yeah and i have
seven reasons to think that she's one of
them or she has morality peristetica and
she's wearing a really tight belt come
on house shape up reason number one
she knew what it was without us telling
her that's true but she could have also
been just acting tough you know because
some guy challenged her like you two
she's still wet from the snow she's not
shivering that's odd
unless she can't sweat or feel hot and
cold the ambulance was warm
i want to see my mother three scarring
around the lips and tongue when she was
a baby she chewed on herself without
feeling it i fell through a window when
i was a kid four
you cleaned the wound she flexed into
the cleaner and set away from it
it's hard to fake pain when you've never
felt it
takes an imaginative leap miss
morgenthal she wants to see her mom she
admits having sifa she knows we're not
letting her go anywhere without a
battery of tests if she already knows
she has sepa why run the battery of test
i feel like house just like wasting
hospital resources taking her to see her
mom
imagine he's wrong and he just hit a
poor kid
oh why am i laughing is this a real case
or one of those imaginary cases that
happen when you're bored sipa
sipa is a diagnosis
diagnoses happen at the end of cases
thank you she's got no idea what's going
on in her body it's bound to be
something wrong in other words she could
be perfectly healthy but you're curious
about someone who can't feel pain
because you always feel pain so you want
to go exploring or maybe because she has
sipa and was just involved in a major
car accident you should pan scan her
make sure she doesn't have internal
bleeding or injuries which would be a
very simple test that house doesn't need
to be present for and he can go home she
was in a car accident
she eats x-rays blood tests eeg nerve
biopsy what does she need an eg for what
are you looking for if she's having a
seizure right now you can see if she's
having a seizure do your test
accept the nerve biopsy you need the
nerves you'd risk paralyzing her what do
you need a nerve biopsy for i get it if
it's congenital we know there's no need
looking for a biopsy and a cause if the
eeg reveals a problem we can talk then
but the eeg is not a defining test eeg
is going to show you brain waves like
what is that going to tell you maybe
they meant an emg
and they're just using the wrong acronym
that's an eeg no idea why they're doing
it spiking on leads c3 and o2 you could
be going into a seizure oh what is this
i don't understand she could be you
can't see it what do you want us to do
hold her down
well only until you inject her with a
sedative then you can let her go we
tried
seriously
she's strong and doesn't care we'd have
broken something before we can get her
to sit still enough to inject her so
break her arm
she won't mind
you're cranky i'm in pain and he's
jealous of her for not being in pain
little does he know a world without pain
is a much more dangerous and problematic
world than with pain
ironic every morning i have to check my
eyes to make sure i didn't scratch a
corny in my sleep oh god stop i'm in a
pool of tears here i can't cry neither
can i
every morning
i check my eyes for jaundice
his vicodins finally shot my liver i
can't run anywhere without examining all
my toes for swelling i can't run it's
opposite ends of the spectrum neither
are good that's why we have
homeostasis
i'm sick
no your eg was normal x-ray showed no
breaks blood tests showed no infections
urine indicated don't
okay okay okay
you do not call a code because someone
becomes unresponsive she could be having
a seizure you don't need to call a coat
a coat is when someone's heart stops
need ice packs and cooling blankets
for what
do you know what the condition is she's
not blush she's not sweating you must be
she has a temperature of 105.
how does she know
oh because the thermometer was still
hanging on her mouth normally if you are
a healthy adult a fever will be
controlled if you have a rare condition
it can go out of control and actually
cause harm to your body that is why i am
a proponent of in certain instances
decreasing the amount of tylenol advil
motrin that we give to patients when
they have a mild fever because a mild
fever generally speaking doesn't do harm
in fact it allows your immune system to
work better and fight off infections
make your symptoms go away faster
improve your immune system make you uh
spend less time being infectious
infecting other people so like in this
case this is the rare instance where her
fever can fry her brain what if
we give her more pain signals
a lot more pain signals maybe some of
them will make it through you want to
torture her no
yes we do this to anybody else it's
torture doing it to her is no different
than pricking her finger we keep poking
sharp sticks into her eventually we'll
find the part that's already tender
that's the most ridiculous thing i ever
heard of on the off chance that maybe
she might feel something and maybe we'll
poke the right area what if it's
internal what are you gonna do then
chief is warm the other
it's very hot
start here move to the hot one just a
few seconds
then back we're going to monitor
activity in your brain while you do it
if you feel any response to the heat
it could indicate a vascular problem
what she's still in surgery they tell me
it's going okay you can take a hand out
and you didn't ask anything else
take your hand out of the water
what's going on with my mother
you just got second degree burns
because you put her arm in scalding
water
doctor i didn't feel anything when you
guys screwed this thing into my head
replace missing chemicals in your nerves
heightened sensitivity
what on what planet this would never
happen
oh my god honestly i wish i was this
girl simply so i could sue this hospital
and become a billionaire judge jury they
drilled into my skull
because maybe they thought i'd feel it
i win that's it i win
so what i just said here will you guys
drill a hole in me
just think about it if they drill like a
centimeter too deep and hurt her brain
and she becomes
functionally impaired
then what
like the pros and cons of this are
terrible stop the drill
it's okay
what you feel
where did you feel it
hannah i need to know how it hurt
what just happened ninja what did the
nerve biopsy show never did it well then
do it can't why
she's gonna jump off the lobby balcony
you think i can catch her
house is an ass
but what did he expect house to do
like for real though like maybe call
security i don't know like what do you
want from us what do you want us to
i do feel my legs you're trying to pull
the same stunt twice in 10 minutes i'm
not pretending they don't hurt they're
just
there
[Music]
they couldn't have put something below
her so that if she did jump she would at
least have a padded surface
[Music]
anything
we're not looking for pain anything at
all pressure nothing
you have six broken bones a fever a
concussion erratic heart rhythms and a
complete lack of sensation below the
waist
i feel fine
guilt
guilt
as a symptom i've never heard of that
alzheimer's can cause euphoria pain
causes depression and b12 deficiency
causes guilt if she had a b12 deficiency
she would have been anemic they would
have seen that on the cbc give her a
shot of b12 if she gets better that was
right
or check her levels like i don't
understand i'm not happy
her white blood cell count was low once
she's got
just a lot of eosinophils hyacinophils
could be a worm parasitic infection
is it possible for you to just watch me
eat
or do you get some primeval thrill out
of beating the other hunters to the food
b12 deficiency are you having deja vu
we've had this conversation she was
given b12 she didn't get better oh maybe
she lacks intrinsic factor to bind it
because someone else ate it
get an abdominal mri what
asha has a word what are you doing
15. you're not going to anesthetize her
relax it's just a magic trick
speaking
lake fishing can be fun
it can bring the generations together
they don't cook that trout or perch well
i'd be giving room and board to this
fella
by free board i mean i'll b12 you could
take in a tapeworm essentially starts
feeding on the foods that you're
consuming so it literally takes away
nutrients from you most commonly you can
get a b12 deficiency but then you would
also get a resulting anemia which is why
this episode's a little confusing
because they said the cbc was normal
outside of a low white count
it's gotta be 25 feet long damn it
world record's over 60. they didn't see
the tapeworm on all of the imaging that
they did this girl's case is interesting
because she has this condition
she doesn't feel anything therefore
she's not aware of the tapeworm and
that's not unusual a lot of people won't
be aware of a tapeworm but because she
has this tapeworm was not getting b12
she essentially started having
neurologic complications as well as
having a fever because of the
infestation of the worm and all these
other symptoms popped up but at the same
time they didn't pop up like they
normally would in a healthy individual
her presentation was masked because she
has the condition sipa detox tea is a
scam click here to check that out
wednesday checkup video it's a throwback
as always stay happy and healthy
[Music]
you